thank you everybody for coming this is
incredibly exciting panel uh when I got
invited to moderate it I was really
impressed i said i'm going to moderate
them this is like you know they invited
the monkey to run the zoo but but here I
am we got incredible panelists we're
going to go John Weiner has dreamed all
his life of a panel that went in Reverse
alphabetical order so that's what we're
going to do we're going to go in reverse
alphabetical order except that John Dean
wants to go last so he's going to go out
of order if turn off your cell phones
okay john is a genuine intellectual he
writes about history and and he writes
for new york times magazine New Republic
his new book is historians in trouble if
there is ever a cable station for
intellectuals this will be the Desperate
Housewives um no it's true it's true i
mean the first the first historian is
like this demon witch that you know like
that that evil female career woman that
always shows up in hollywood movies and
except in this book she could get she it
has a happy ending to a high
administrative post by the Bush
administration let's see
science friction which is Michael
sharma's book michael has been a
defender of rationality for years and
years and years he's the publisher of
skeptic he's the guy who came out with
the idea of calling people who actually
think brights and he's also the author
of why people believe weird things how
we believe the science of good and evil
and what I think what you know kind of
what I think is going on here the title
of the panel is this seat something in
the seats deception and cover up so you
know Jon Jon's new book is dealing with
historians and this is a field in which
accuracy and accountability and being
able to prove what you say or the gold
standard that's what you're supposed to
do Michael's book is about how we not
not so much as current book but his
previous books are about how people
believe and why they believe in why they
believe in stupid thinks which is
probably the the the most important
issue in America today
most of you know I mean there there is a
paper on the east coast with a name
really similar to the one that sponsors
this festival probably every literate
person in the world has read that
newspaper and I assume you were
illiterate because you're too book fair
so in that case you've all read Maureen
Dowd who's been you know right there on
the scene with Bush one Bush to Bush two
and a half and and she also has a Pew
lat surprised okay her book is Bush
world there it is push world enter at
your own risk and okay Eric Alterman
media critic eric is best known for what
liberal media the truth about bias in
the news and in which he proved
conclusively that Maureen Dowd is
actually a conservative his new book is
is when presidents lie I thought the
subtitle is going to be when their lips
move but but what the subtitle is a
history of official deception and its
consequences and the consequences now
seem to be get reelected and which it
was which it was on the Nixon right and
John Dee
John is the only Republican that I'm
aware of it turned into a really good
writer he's also he's his current book
is worse than watergate and he is also
the author of lost honor the rehnquist
choice of biography of Warren Harding
and blind ambition okay John in Reverse
alphabetical order go port well it's a
it's a real honor in a thrill to be
sitting next to John Dean and on a panel
with Maureen Dowd let me tell you who
Larry by nerd is Larry Boehner its new
because the librarian but but this this
is the man who wrote wag the dog this is
the man who wrote wag the dog
anyway I'm interested in why it is that
when academics professors historians are
accused of misconduct that sometimes
they end up on page one and find their
careers ruined and sometimes they end up
appointed by President Bush to important
offices historians have been in the news
a lot lately and the news has not been
that good you may know of Ward Churchill
the ethnic studies professor Colorado
who the governor wanted to fire for his
outrageous statements about some of the
victims of 911 maybe you heard about
middle east studies at Columbia where
professors there have been charged with
abusive treatment of students I I'm
interested in talking today about two
cases of research misconduct by
historians one of which resulted in a
career-ending and one of which resulted
in a bush white house appointment and I
want to start with the latter the
current national archivist of the United
States now probably most of you don't
care too much about this but John Dean
cares about this and I care about this
the current archivist is a man named
should care you should care thank you
thank you he's a man named Alan
Weinstein he was nominated by a george
bush and took office just last month he
has written he's a scholar a historian
of Soviet espionage in the United States
and he has been charged with research
misconduct in his two most important
books the most recent one is called The
Haunted wood it's a history of Soviet
espionage in the United States that's
based on the archives of the KGB but
what Alan Weinstein did was he he he and
his publisher paid for exclusive access
to this archive they paid a hundred
thousand dollars to the KGB retirement
fund and in exchange for the hundred
thousand dollars they not only got
access to the documents but they got
exclusive access which means no one else
is allowed to see the documents that
they cite now this is not only a bad
idea for people who wonder if Alan
Weinstein quoted the documents correctly
it's also a violation of the code of
ethics of the International Association
of archivists which says the principle
is that documents should be open to
everyone so of the job of national
archivist the National Archives is the
place where the official secrets of the
United States are kept and the public
oui oui of course want to know as much
about our government as possible because
of course democracy depends on an
informed electorate and presidents all
have secrets Democrats as well as
Republicans have secrets so it's the job
of the archivist to represent the public
in its quest for information about what
government is doing access to documents
is what this job is about but the person
that George Bush appointed to be in
charge of the secrets to be representing
us in our effort to find out information
about what the government is doing
himself has a record of paying archives
to keep their documents secret from his
own critics this seems wrong
but it's not the first time he's done it
his previous book was called perjury
it's a history of the Alger Hiss
Whittaker Chambers case which was
crucial in the beginnings of the of the
Cold War in that k that was a book based
largely on interviews and it came out
almost 25 years ago in that book the it
was considered to have provided
conclusive evidence that Alger Hiss was
guilty as charged of spying for the
Soviet Union in the 30s and 40s but the
editor of the Nation magazine Victor
Navasky person who eric alterman rights
for regularly and I write for
intermittently did a very simple fact
check he got in touch with the first six
people interviewed in the book ask them
if they'd been quoted correctly and they
all said no one hundred percent of them
say they'd been misrepresented misquoted
or otherwise their position had been
distorted now everyone who does
interviews knows that often the people
you interview are unhappy with the way
their interviews turn out in print it
wasn't what they hoped for it wasn't
what they thought you were going to do
it happens so this doesn't mean that
Alan Weinstein is necessarily wrong
about this but the way to do it and he
knew what to do he said he would make
the tapes of his interviews available to
Victor Navasky the Nation magazine and
anybody else who wanted to see them that
was in 1980 to this day no one has ever
been allowed none of the critics have
ever been allowed to see those documents
only the Friends of Alan Weinstein had
been allowed to see those documents now
well this seems a bit deceptive it's
also a violation of the statement on
standards of the american historical
association and of the association of
oral historians which says that oral
history documents are supposed to be
made available to other researchers as
an appropriate at an appropriate archive
like the UCLA oral history archive the
Columbia oral history archive that's
what he was supposed to do he knew he
was supposed to do that he promised to
do that he even signed a deed
gift Alan Weinstein did that he would
deposit these at the Truman library in
Missouri Truman library never got them
so here's a guy it's almost as if the
White House said here is a historian who
has spent 20 years stonewalling his
critics he's our kind of guy and that's
the man that's the man who's in charge
of the official records of all of us of
our government now the contrast I want
to make in the minute I have left the
opposite the opposite fate Michael belly
L wrote a book called arming America is
the history of gun culture in the United
States it argued that Americans had
fewer guns in the late eighteenth and
early nineteenth century then historians
had previously believed this was taken
to be a significant argument about gun
control today although I'm not really
sure it has much to do with whether
there are too many guns today but there
were serious questions raised about his
documentation unlike Alan Weinstein
Michael Belle île provided his critics
with all of his documentation he gave
him all of his materials told him what
archives he'd been to turned out he'd
screwed up a lot of this it there was a
lot of errors in what he did a
distinguished committee of historians
concluded in fact that he was guilty of
fraud in one of his tables and he
resigned a position as tenured professor
of history at Emory University now one
of Michael billy'll historian of gun
culture in America had done what Alan
Weinstein did had refused to share his
archival documents had refused to make
his materials available to other
scholars there would have been a
tremendous outcry why was it why was it
that the critic of the of the gun lobby
had his career ended while the person
with ties to the Republican White House
had his career advanced and why was it
that the stories told in the media about
this where that Michael Belle île was
guilty of research fraud while no one
seemed to care about the questions
raised about Alan Weinstein
except for Eric Alterman and me actually
and vicar and Victor who's on another
panel at this hour I conclude that the
right has been much more successful than
the left when it comes to cases of
charges of misconduct by historians the
right has been able to reward those it
considers its allies and punish those it
considers its enemies and that's all I
have to say about this good morning how
we doing I have to stand up for this I'm
going to do a psychic reading so you
have to stand up for this hi I'm Michael
Shermer the director of the skeptics
society and the publisher of skeptic
magazine we investigate claims of the
paranormal pseudoscience fringe groups
and cults and claims of all kinds
between science pseudoscience
non-science bad science voodoo science
junk science non-science and nonsense
and as you may have noticed there's a
lot of that out there some people call
us debunkers but let's face it there's a
lot of bunk that needs debunking so in
my five minutes I'm just going to
basically talk about psychics and
deception because they go together and
and then cult leaders and conspiracy
theorists and then finally the general
concept of deception as a whole so we
begin with what we do kind of like trash
collecting that's a dirty job but
somebody's got to do it that is to bunk
the psychics because it looks like they
are able to read people's minds and talk
to the dead that kind of thing oh I
should point out anybody can talk to the
dead it's getting the dead to talk back
that's the difficult part
and that's where the deception comes in
it looks something like this there's
some spirits in the room coming through
here just a moment yes somebody on this
side of the room has lost somebody it
passed over which is convenient since
I'm standing on this side of the room
and the cameras are right here that's
how it works in these studio audiences
it's funny how the dead congregate in
television studios in New York and Los
Angeles but that's you know that's the
way the spirit world works and so
there's somebody coming through I'm
getting something around here like a an
our name a robber to Richard something
like that a father figure could be a
grandfather grandmother mother father
uncle close friend of some kind yes I
think it's you sir yes I do i do think
it's here you were nodding in a certain
way hang on just a minute yes he's
telling me something about in your
garage you have some power tools that
are broken that you've been meaning to
fix right and how did I know but they
told me and you ma'am I'm being told
something about you have a box of
photographs in your closet you've been
meaning to put into photo albums you
know sir I'm getting something about
there's I see a calendar on your wall
talent it's an out-of-date calendar
you've been meaning to take it down it's
an old for calendar most importantly you
ma'am I'm getting something about how
you're a thoughtful intelligent good
communicator with a good sense of humor
you're shy sometimes but at other times
you're outgoing
all right why would anybody fall for
this kind of stick and i'm not i'm not
particularly good at I don't do it very
often if I did it a couple hours a day
like the pros you know you'd get much
smoother at it and it's because people
want to believe that it's true it's a
confirmation bias you look for and
accept confirmatory evidence which you
already believe and then you just filter
out all the rest it doesn't fit you
remember the head to forget the missus
so if I were to do an actual reading on
you did you used to wear your hair
longer when you were younger by the way
and there's something about an earring
you've got you have app you have one
that you're missing the other and you're
hanging onto it because you're hoping to
but there's a whole book of this stuff
this is kind of spiel you can use all
right so are these psychics deceptive
intentionally I'm not sure I think for
sure some of them are that is they are
out-and-out con artists fraudulently
deceiving the public to make money
that's true but that's not very
interesting to me that's just like a
street con what's more interesting is
the possibility that they've
self-deceived they convince themselves
they can do this because with practice
they've gotten better at it and better
at it and you the people coming for the
readings give them positive feedback
which makes them more confident and the
more confident you are the better you
get at it the more convincing you are to
your clients who then are ever more
convinced you're real and feedback on
that and that's why I think most cult
leaders are not out in art fraud con
artists I think they believed the lie
and if you believe the lie then your
body and face does not give off the cues
of line so sort of wrap it up here I
think there was an evolutionary arms
race in the long history of human
evolution between line and line
detection I think we're pretty good
liars and pretty good lie detectors I
think the liars have a slight advantage
over the lie detectors unless you spend
a lot of time with somebody and then you
can collect enough data to have a sense
that they're trustworthy or not and so I
think when we encounter somebody once
they can get away with the lie you can
you can buy into the deceit when you
interact with somebody a lot it's a lot
harder to do it because they start
giving off those subtle cues and there's
a
steen research on this now about facial
expressions and cues that we give off
you know when you when you look at the
camera and say I did not have sexual
relations without woman Medellin you
think this guy is really good but you
know he's lying all right so if with
enough exposure to that individual it
becomes clear there's something off
there there's something untrustworthy
okay why would that be and I think so
this is sort of where I wrap it up with
the science of good and evil book on how
this all evolved that we evolved as a
social primate species in these small
groups of a couple of dozen to a couple
hundred individuals in which shunning
and other informal social means of
behavior control work just fine to take
care of the liars deceivers cheaters
outliers that the frauds and so on we
can deal with that fine when everybody
knows each other and those kinds of
people through much exposure get exposed
and so on what happens when societies
get large populations get into tens of
thousands hundreds of thousands it's too
easy for the the outliers to hide in the
nooks and crannies of a large society
and that's why I argue this was the
birth of religion and government about
the same time state societies and large
religion religion is a form of behavior
control it's a moral behavior control
it's not just that we're going to shun
you it's that you're not going to get
away with it because mr. big is keeping
track and but even that's not enough
because there are some people who don't
care if mr. big is keeping track so we
have to deal with them in the here and
now and that's what you need the state
for and that's how we got to where we
are basically in seven minutes thank
well can you guys hear me yeah I didn't
know I was supposed to prepare something
so I'm gonna be a little inarticulate
here but that's okay because even when I
prepare I'm inarticulate so you're not
going to notice the difference my
favorite quote about Washington is one
that Russell Baker said in his memoir
which was that covering Washington was
just a matter of sitting in ever grander
marble halls waiting for someone ever
more important to come out and lied to
you and I grew up in Washington and my
brothers were Capitol Hill pages in the
50s and you know they their job was
mostly to you know when senators would
get drunk they get the brass spittoons
you know they'd you know step into them
and not be able to get them off their
legs and my brother would have to pull
it off or when their wives would call
you know different senators and they'd
be in their hideaway offices with their
mistresses my brothers would have to
keep the wife from coming so I never
actually grew up thinking Washington was
um you know a totally pure place but my
dad was a police detective who was in
charge of Capitol Hill security and he
would judge politicians by whether they
were phony or not and he was born in
Ireland and his favorite phrase was you
know they're full of prunes so and I
think I took that on kind of as an
ideology because he would never mention
their party he would just say they're a
phony or they're not a phony so um when
I wrote Bush world I you know I I wished
I were evil in law because only he could
do justice to the story which is to me
one of the most amazing it's like a
heist story i call it oceans 911 because
although Wolfowitz is no brad pitt
because these guys took all of our
emotions and fears that we felt after
911 and diverted them to a plan that had
been in the making and their heads for a
decade at American Enterprise Institute
and it was kind of a perfect storm they
all had different reasons for it but it
was not what they told us it was a
threat to our imminent security so now
it's wearing a very interesting ends
justifies the means situation now and I
have seen enough Shakespearean plays to
know that ends justifies the means
usually ends up with the body littered
with this stage littered with bodies and
the end of the play so I'm very
skeptical about that but everyone now is
saying you know what wasn't Bush right
and don't you shouldn't you apologize to
Wolfowitz weren't they write and to
quote my friend and and fellow colonists
richard cohen it really i don't want to
be i'm not at all sure ish if things go
well in the Middle East I'm thrilled you
know for the sake of our country and the
Middle East and our troops who can come
home sooner but I don't really care if
democracy spreads from the Nile to the
Tigris it is not going to change the
fact that lying to the American people
and ginning up evidence and turning you
know all of our institutions into you
know distorting them to distort truth
for an ideal ideal ideological goal is
right and it's never going to be right
to tell the American people to not tell
the American people the truth about why
you go to war or the families or the
troops so I would never change my mind
about that
you know I as far as just random
thoughts about Washington I mean it's
it's just a remarkable time there
because what we're watching is the
Republicans trying to turn America into
a theocracy while the Bush
administration desperately tries to stop
Iraq from becoming Athiya which is one
of these great circular things in the
same way that Bush 41 went to war with
Saddam in Iraq to establish the
principle that one nation can't
unilaterally invade another and his son
went to war with Saddam in Iraq to
establish the principle that one nation
can unilaterally invade another so
Republicans are better hypocrites you
know they just have a gift and a talent
for it as the nuns would say when I was
little they're just great bold brazen
pieces and they you know they can just
say more outrageous things and then the
Democrats won't have a hard time calling
them on it because they say well free
speech or something so you know I came
across a fly or yesterday that says that
bill o'reilly is going to be leading a
you know on a cruise of Love Boat kind
of cruise in November and it's called a
values for America cruise
and here's the part I love it's to the
Caribbean which is exactly what he got
in trouble on the phone fantasizing that
if he were with this girl in the
Caribbean you know he could lick her her
up and LU for her so so now he's going
to values cruise there so it just proves
that Republicans are geniuses so anyway
thank you very much
thank you you know pick up on something
Maureen said at the beginning for
remarks about how those of us who didn't
think this world was a good idea for any
number of reasons appear to be on the
defensive now for whatever reason to me
this is another example of how
incredibly effective the right has been
at controlling the political discourse I
got a gallup poll emailed me to me on
tuesday i get them at every tuesday
morning and this gallup poll
demonstrated that fifty three percent of
american people think it was a mistake
to go to war in iraq these numbers have
been consistent for the past four months
the previous gallup poll i got the week
before before that looked at george bush
george w bush's popularity ratings and
compared them to previous second-term
presidents at this point in their second
termini is the most unpopular
second-term president at this point in
second time since gallup began doing the
polls and it over and over we hear about
this popular president persecuting the
successful war and that those of us who
warned against it because of what things
that lil later demonstrated to be true
are supposed to be on defensive and
that's I mean that's they've won the
game when when when they've controlled
this course that effectively because you
never get to the actual problems that
they've caused it's all it's all you
know it's that's just that's going to do
with anything except like I got the mic
here and I um last night I spoke in a
synagogue and everybody and I started
talking I picked up this story that I
did read to my daughter and the Bible
recently and there was a rabbi there and
I hassled him about that story and it's
just I got it I got to come a little bit
prepared to these things because
thoughts popping in my head and I and I
go with them a little too long and we've
only got five minutes and I haven't even
mentioned this book here you know this
book that I wrote about presidential
lying called when presidents I thanks I
noticed he didn't hold it up the first
time
it's not a book that some it's not a
book that's actually morally preening
about lying it's not a book that says
lying is always wrong my tell my
daughter's actually here she's got her
headphones on so she can't hear me which
is a good thing because I tell her that
lying is always wrong but the rest of us
should understand that there are times
in our lives you know if if your wife
really does look fat five minutes before
years you're supposed to go to a dinner
party you have to lie more seriously you
know when when Huck Finn and and and and
Jim are on that boat and and there and
the gyms owners are up on the cliff and
demand to know from Huck is his it's his
companion white or black and Huck and
Huck lies and says white that's that's
that's a noble lie that's the
life-saving lie I can't imagine anybody
who would think that Huck would have
done the right thing that he had sent
Jim back into a life of slavery and
degradation merely for telling the truth
Immanuel Kant argues that if there's a
murderer at your door with a gun and he
says where is my intended victim i would
like to go kill them now you have a
moral obligation to tell the truth
because if if you lie then you become
responsible for what happens next and if
you don't lie then it's not your problem
I like to think of manual car wouldn't
really tell the truth in that situation
I like to think he's just being cheeky
with us and that's his very fancy way of
doing so but it's true as we heard the
beginning that most presidents do law
and they line with pretty a a
considerable degree of regularity I
actually I think that George Bush's lies
are the least of our problems I mean I
really don't think George Bush lied any
more than believe it or not Franklin
Roosevelt certainly not more than Lyndon
Johnson and john dean's friend what was
his name
it's the thing about the Bush
administration is not that they lie it's
that they have a contempt for the truth
which is something different Roosevelt
and the book is set up to be a pragmatic
argument for truth in other words
Roosevelt lied about Yalta John Kennedy
lied about the deal that settled the
Cuban Missile Crisis Lyndon Johnson lied
about the Gulf of Tonkin a situation he
didn't lie on the day event he lied a
few days later when he found out the
truth and Ronald Reagan lied about
everything he ever said about Central
America and that all of these presidents
paid a pragmatic price for having lied
that they all would have been much much
better off had they simply told the
truth to the country and bitten the
bullet at the moment but none of them
Roosevelt was quite sick at the time he
died six weeks after he gave his speech
about Yalta so that might be a special
case but I had none of them had the sort
of small form of political courage that
would have been required to tell the
country and unpleasant truth at the
moment and so they ended up finding
themselves in a web of lies which is
actually when you think about it quite
natural because once if a president
tells a consequential lie about
something then he's got to keep lying
because presidents create that their
words create and create a reality and
that reality is separate from the
reality that they were originally
talking about so they end up dealing
with the lies rather than with truth
meanwhile the truth comes back to bite
them in the ass because reality doesn't
go away so in each of those cases each
of these presidents paid a significant
price Roosevelt and Kennedy were not
around pay the price anymore because
they they both died but their parties
paid the price and they would have paid
the price that they state it was in
other words it was a bad political move
seen in the long term and I think that's
organic in the system of the ecosystem
of lying in politics but I think what's
happened is that we've gotten too used
to lying even though like I said it's
not always the worst thing in the world
we've gotten too used to lying and
because our political system has ceased
to hold presidents to any standard of
lying that we don't even really pay
attention to whether or not what they're
saying is lying or the truth it's all a
question of whether
not it it's smooth the workings of the
system that that the Bush administration
has has taken this this insight and it
has metastasized it and so it's not
simply that George that you can't
believe what George Bush says is that
you know that i was listening to your
presentation about how it's scarier that
they believe what they you know it's
more convincing when it's also scarier
that they believe what they say then it
isn't I mean in some ways I would feel
better about the world if I knew Bush
knew we were lying but more
significantly it's that it's that the
truth is is it's not simply lying it's
that the truth becomes irrelevant
there's a quote in my book and I use it
in a cover story I wrote this week in
the nation about the attack on the media
from michael kinsley that this
administration they give the impression
of that the fact that they lie because
they can't be bothered to tell the truth
if they told if they could if the
telling the truth were easier they would
do that it's just too much of a hassle
but the seems to me who's really at
fault here are the media because the
media come back the next day for more
lies they're quite aware that they're
being lied to I mean just last in the
last week there were two very
significant pieces of legislation that
what completely under the radar having
one having to do with mercury emissions
are they selling the standard for
mercury image is another one having to
do for nuclear storage in the yuca
mountains now these are complicated
issues and intelligence I don't
understand them all that well but I do
know that the administration's suppress
the studies that they themselves had
commissioned because those studies did
not demonstrate what the administration
want to show which was that hey it's
okay to do whatever we want to do in the
first goddamn place now those studies
the the people who who who made these
studies the scientists both inside and
outside the administration put
themselves on the line and said hey no
this is not the case if you remember you
can you can pick almost any issue you
want when this happens same thing
happened with it when they rewrote the
Medicare issues where they had they shut
up that Gallio said he'd be fired if he
lets happens over and over and over
again okay and they denied that these
studies existed at first and then they
don't know I they said they they didn't
finish whatever they went over and over
entirely unbelievably and the story
disappears
the story disappears in part because
it's not that sexy in part because it
doesn't involve Michael Jackson and
small boys or there's no little blonde
girl to get bulletins on every night it
in other words part of the problem is is
tabloid ization part of the problem is a
lack of attention span on the media but
part of the problem is they just won't
stand up to this administration and and
say damn it we're tired of being lied to
we're not going to accept that standard
we blend is dis very different I'll stop
there mr. Dean the reason I wanted to go
last is I'm not sure why I'm on this
panel now these these people all right
about lies deceit and cover-ups so they
are secondary sources i guess they put
me here as a primary source fidelity and
and as a primary source I sort of looked
over this panel and and got to know a
little bit about them I knew some of
them beforehand certainly I knew Maureen
who I've been reading since before my
hair turned gray but remarkably sures is
not and she looks younger than ever and
I know Larry's work and i must say that
do yourself a favor google his name go
to his website and look under his
multimedia files for something called
war on as in war on drugs war on poverty
and have a treat and larry i must say i
didn't know about the war on
masturbation
I was also thinking as I pulled up my
seats being attracted to attractive
Maureen's I'm not real glad that this is
being on broadcast on c-span my
attractive Maureen might wonder where
I'm sitting today Eric I know because I
had the pleasure of reviewing for the
Washington Monthly his win president
slide I also happen to read his
dissertation which he is is the first
part of the book and he's the only guy
I've ever met in my life who has a PhD
in presidential line so so after I after
I read his dissertation I wondered to
Stanford pass those out for real life
experiences as well Michael I must say
that your your work why people believe
in weird things I've always suspected
because they were weird people that was
something of an epiphany for me so I
last night pulled it off the shelf and
opened up to the the moment I remembered
in reading the book or I saw probably
the most perfect description of the
White House staff I'd ever read and I'm
not talking just about the staff I was
on but those who preceded and followed
me which I had a chance to study let me
just read the bullet points from this
section on page 119 veneration of the
leader in aaron c of the leader
omniscience of the leader persuasive
techniques hidden agendas deceit
financial and/or sexual exploitation
absolute truth absolute morality well
he's not describing a white house he's
describing the elements of a cult and
who afraid that michael is an awfully
good description of most white house's
it scary a little scary John I know
because I've had the pleasure of doing
his radio program on kpfk
them on a couple of occasions and it's a
it's unusual talk radio it's unusual in
the fact that it's actually intelligent
talk radio so he and I as he said do
share our concern about what's going to
happen to presidential records after
this presidency leaves something I've
written at some length about in my worse
than watergate book what I'm hoping John
might get into today is a piece he wrote
some years ago that stuck in my mind
back in in the mid 80s late 80s where he
found the real Nancy Davis and not Nancy
Davis Reagan a rather a Nancy Davis who
was flipping hamburgers in Ventura
County and had been the purported reason
that Ronnie and Nancy got together well
he kind of put the light of that story
and I'm hoping he'll share how he found
her and how he put the locket of that
story today because it's fascinating
that this woman says she was never a
communist she threatened that if Nancy
Davis Reagan kept saying so she was
going to sue her she stopped saying it
for a few years then she resumed again
and it's of course become the official
myth of that presidency and and the
meaning of these people so I guess I'm
here obviously to provide fair and
balanced coverage of this big thank you
I think what we're going to do is find
out if we have questions for each other
and if we do we'll we'll talk a little
here open the microphone in the middle
there for questions from you um um
Michael I have a question for you okay
so here we are we have a administration
that as Maureen said is we're turning
trying to turn the country into a
theocracy and it's always been my sense
that the only difference between
believing and weird cults and or
actually I read a psychiatric definition
that the only difference between a
delusional belief and an acceptable
belief like a religion is the number of
people who believe in it um then this is
your your area of expertise so my
question is how do we separate out what
is delusional and what is a sensible
belief and why why has delusional belief
become an acceptable standard today I
mean they do there was the study of the
people who voted for Bush were all
deluded about what he what he believed
in what other people believed in and
whether they were weapons of mass
destructions of what wow I knew you were
going to say that right
so turn on your telepathic powers right
now yeah well that's a mouthful gosh
there's a lot there issues that we deal
with separation of church and state sob
viously a big one for us specifically
with things like attempts to teach
creationism in public schools which has
a political and religious agenda behind
it and the current administration's sort
of emphasis on on faith how do you tell
the difference well that's what science
does better than anything else and this
is why I'm such a pro science guys
because as deeply flawed as it may be
and conducted by humans who are subject
to all the same bias eases everybody
else like the confirmation bias looking
for the hits and ignoring the misses and
so on it has a self-correcting machinery
built into it which requires you to look
for your own misses and mistakes and
biases because if you don't one of your
colleagues with great Glee will point it
out and so in that sense science is also
very competitive and it's one of the
reasons I trust the system it's not a
faith in science so much as it is
confidence from its experience of being
so productive and useful and good at
what it does that it it is the best
system we have for telling the
difference between these things and
whatever the particular claim is the
problem is when it's loaded with say
religious or political implications then
it's harder to get at it so for example
recently I was disturbed by this
observations when Michael Crichton's
book state of fear came out the same
week that Jared Diamond's collapse came
out and it was very predictable I could
tell already what the reviews would say
based on who wrote it and where the
review was published I didn't have to
read a single word wall street journal
of course they're going to hate Jared's
collapse and of course they're going to
love Crichton's book predictable Reason
magazine libertarian magazine that I
readin like but they predictably love
Crichton's book and we're skeptical of
jared's book New York Times love
collapse hated and said I times hated
state of fear so there's something
disturbing about that and I think part
of the problem is is that
in complicated scientific questions like
environmental questions where the models
are really complex and there's loaded
with so many variables that it's really
hard to say then the data don't just
speak for themselves and you end up
filtering them through these theories
the theories that themselves are loaded
with political or religious ideologies
and biases and so I I find myself very
torrent on say environmental issues in
global warming because it's not clear
it's clear that the earth is getting
warmer say for example the last hundred
years but it's not clear whether this is
a part of a Thousand Year 10,000 year
hundred thousand year warming or cooling
trend that could be partially human
cause partially naturally caused and so
it's very complex and that's why when
you see you know that one network has
the left-wing scientists on and the
other one has the right wing scientists
what which which what why aren't there
scientists with no wings
Oh which one's had the left wings yeah
Oh ABC NBC CBS really is CNN yeah yeah
they do they do so there that's it will
pay good make you an honorary member of
the skeptics is that you should be
skeptical of the skeptics by the way I
should put that so you know that in
short that's the problem the facts don't
just speak for themselves on these hard
issues can I smell Rena question meriem
you you you covered the bush senior
White House's White House correspondent
in both bush I wonder what its you have
a relationship with them as a result of
your work Bush her nickname is Cobra
Cobra they call her the Cobra and brush
is a lot better than turd blossom which
is what he calls his best friend and and
the bush senior complained that you put
him on the couch what what do you make
of this water well both the father and
the Son complain about being put on the
couch if you ask them questions that
aren't about politics but in both cases
I was just asking I was doing a cultural
interview with both of them so I was
just asking what's your favorite movie
or do you watch TV and they would say
don't put me on the couch don't
psychoanalyze me so they're very even
this president who is all textin all the
time but they have that lost thing of
not wanting to be introspective and you
know it's interesting
don't god I know wasps or the last group
you can't make fun of but um when Eric
was talking I did remember one thing I
wanted to say which is um when I did ask
Pat elephant whose brilliant I think to
do my cover I started to tell him what I
wanted and he goes stop I I read your
column I know and he did exactly what I
wanted which was to have a cover that
conveyed a different reality and that
was the point of the subtext you know
that they didn't like the reality they
were faced with in Iraq where they
couldn't prove you know there was any
reason to go to war so they created
their own reality and it's interesting
because ron suskind did this piece for
the new york times and there was a White
House official who actually gave a quote
that said Oh journalists you know you're
in the reality-based community as though
reality were something else you know and
and he said they created their own
reality so it's not you know it's it's
it's way beyond lying it's like just
taking a reality and since the president
doesn't read the newspapers or anything
you know Cheney can put if he has a
fever about going to war with luck he
can just put a filter on the information
that he gets and condi you know suppress
information and studies that would have
debunked things so they suppress
everything that would have debunked
things and ginned up everything that
didn't and the father and son are
similar in one sense i mean the son ran
away from everything about the father
the father was an internationalist so
the Sun had to be unilateral is the
father was a Episcopalian so the Sun had
to be an event Jellicle so you know the
father was sort of Greenwich so the Sun
had to be West Texas and so but the one
thing that they're like in is they don't
really connect words and actions and
they um you know the father when he he
got in trouble for saying read my you
know lips no new taxes he didn't
understand that was a pledge he thought
that was just a line that Peggy Noonan
put in the speech to make him seem like
Gary Cooper he was
you know and the Sun is the same way and
they have this we know best we'll handle
it you the American public have not been
bred to lead we will handle it and then
we'll let you know how it comes out and
that's where I differ with them so yeah
well I just would like to add a footnote
that it really expands way beyond the
bushes themselves the study you referred
to with the University of Maryland which
I cited in my book is just a phenomenal
analysis of what's going on just the
week before everyone went to the poll
last November at the University of
Maryland with a totally non or
unpartitioned study tried to find out
the attitudes of bush voters versus
carry voters what they found is pretty
startling for example on the issue of
weapons of mass destruction they found
that seventy two percent of the bush
voters believed there were weapons of
mass destruction in Iraq justifying the
invasion of Iraq they believed that
seventy five percent of the bush voters
believed that there was a tie between
al-qaeda and Saddam Hussein yes some of
the Kerry voters got it wrong it was
around in the low 20s big so we did have
totally different realities when I tried
to dig a little deeper which the
Maryland study did not do but try to
look to see where this misinformation is
coming from I've got to share with you a
lot of us coming from pulpits where the
ministers are telling the flock what
they should believe and they're
believing it
by the way a footnote to that there was
a previous study by the same program on
policy attitudes at University of
Maryland about where people get the
information and eighty-one percent of
fox news viewers believed through all
three of the lies that they set up and
only twenty-two percent of the people
who said that their primary news source
was other than New York Times CBS News
or NPR believed even one of those lies
and there's of course a direct
correlation between believing those
lives and supporting the war and not and
so you really had to believe something
that was false to support the war here's
my question for mr. Dean you know I used
to I played kind of a macaw game with
myself up leading up till november or i
guess it was up to john kerry got the
nature of who i would support over if
they were running against george bush i
would i would happily have supported his
dad if he had gotten the Democratic
nomination I would happily have
supported Bob Dole I toyed with myself
about Richard Nixon I went back and
forth and I'll tell you why and then I
want you to get a good green candidate
but here's here's what I'm here's here's
actually the serious point of my
question Nixon was a weirdo for sure and
you know he would send in Fred Malek to
go count the Jews make sure they weren't
too many Jews in any one department but
the Nixon administration for all of the
psychosis that manifested itself on
those tapes it seemed to have a real
respect for competence and they had some
tough guys and some audio logs and the
same is actually two of Ronald Reagan
but there wasn't a sense that that
everybody has to be on board with
everything and that we can't allow
anyone almost almost like kind of like
the polymer we can't allow anyone to
speak anything that's off the
reservation at all and yet in in the
bush administration as I was trying to
communicate earlier it's not just a
simple matter of people giving them
completely convenient
sir to every question it's that across
the board the there's sort of an
ideological answer to every single
matter and it sits in the Justice
Department the environmental Department
and the Department of Interior in in HHS
you know and it says if reality doesn't
enter into the question or if it does
it's something that needs to be
explained away which was not true of
next and it was not nearly as to his rig
and it certainly wasn't it's true of
george herbert walker bush now i have i
have two hypotheses that i'd like to run
by you of what's changed and I don't
want you to tell me what you think it is
and I'm not saying i'm right about
either one one is is that they didn't
have in your day they didn't have fox
news they didn't have this entire right
wing media structure that is willing to
go out and say yes in fact we have found
weapons of mass destruction and dan
Rather doesn't want you to know about it
and so that the whole idea of a
normative set of facts that we can agree
on has been lost because the so much of
our news is entirely ideology and the
second change is that in those days
there was a republican party that was
that had a multiplicity of views and now
if there's anybody in the Republican
Party who doesn't believe that the
United States is a divinely inspired
experiment by God and that everything we
do is therefore blessed by God you don't
hear much from them in other words
there's this religious certainty that is
that it is expressed and there's no one
if you even question a religious
certainty you're questioning the whole
edifice so it seems to me that when you
add those two things together this
terrifying religious certainty these
people have and the fact that that
within the structure that's set up in
the Constitution to keep our democracy
accountable there are people undermining
it there are structures there to
undermine it that they can get away with
a lot more than you guys get away with
before you became such a great guy
Eric either subject would be a good book
but let me give you a quick answer
you're right there was no Fox News in
fact the media before Watergate was an
entirely different media than we have
post-watergate before Watergate
presidents were generally given the
benefit of the doubt and assumed to be
doing the right thing post-watergate
they were soon to be guilty and they had
until they proved a negative that they
were innocent that was really the case
up until two thousand and it's sort of
hung on for Al Gore even during the 2000
campaign but not very much for George
Bush from the get-go he was given a pass
and there's no question that there is a
whole other element with talk radio and
and the the right having its chorus out
there to keep banging away on their key
talking points today what's interesting
is that Nixon used to complain about the
fact that this wasn't the case he's the
one who said we don't have enough
right-wing think tanks we don't have
enough right-wing media and he was very
much on this case and had he completed a
second term I suspect some of these
actions would have taken place much
sooner than they did so that he was very
aware of this problem and it has changed
the complexion as far as the GOP and and
and the Republican Party but you've got
to remember where this whole change in
the party where it goes below the
mason-dixon line and finds the
conservatives who used to be Democrats
who are now all Republicans this starts
with really Goldwater Goldwater doing it
with some success Nixon seen the door
open going through in 68 but then being
one out being totally outdone by George
Wallace who could far out demon eyes and
politicize the so-called wedge issues
then Richard Nixon could begin to but in
72 Nixon reached again and brought a lot
of those people into the tent
and that's what started changing the the
complexion of the party I must say that
I don't think my views have changed a
whole lot but i find myself away on the
left today as opposed to where the
republican party is so there there have
been changes and they do in impact but i
would add one other thing that every
president has a tremendous impact on the
way his government and his
administration works if a president
wears hats his staff his wearing hats if
a president has fires in the fireplace
in the Oval Office his staff does the
same it's it's remarkable how these
patterns start and you've got a unique
situation with this presidency and that
I'm not sure who's running the show
you've got one guy who's a salesman and
the other guy who's minding the store in
Dick Cheney and that really has
influenced a lot Cheney might well be
open to let's listening to alternative
views I don't think George Bush is so
that's influenced tremendously the way
this presidency operates if we have
questions from the floor you got to go
up to the microphone there and I see
somebody's up there already and yeah hi
mr. Dean on great respect for you and
how you've come out like you have and
you're riding at findlaw com I can tell
exactly who's running the show with the
bush regime it's the lacuna me Oh
conservatives most of whom are Jewish is
mr. Alterman had written about in his
nation magazine piece can we talk I mean
I hear you're mischaracterize I like to
justify the Bamford book that explains
this in detail I need to say that I hope
to stay on the record I didn't say that
and I wouldn't say that an article from
April 21st 2003 I've it in my hand and
you said it does the taboo to talk about
the lacuna neocon agenda jus the jewish
institute for national security affairs
in rochester new American Century why
are we talking about James Bamford is
pretext for war book he should be on
this panel it's a disgrace that he's not
and he's never been invited to this
discussion I sure or the festival's ever
thank you next please
I promise not to be as rancorous it's
see it seems that the right the right in
politics today have learned effectively
that consumerism and creating a product
through lying and associations and
developing a strong support system on
the religious right and other aspects of
the right have really really nailed it
in terms of how to sell themselves and I
wonder whether the left is shooting
themselves in the foot by maintaining a
kind of moral high ground about being
truthful and it essentially should they
be learning how to package themselves
and are they going to be the second
party in this country forever because
they are not haven't learned that lesson
so is lying okay and necessary in a
consumer culture is the issue anybody
got an answer to that that's a big
country I think I think the trick is to
learn how to package whatever it is that
you got rather than make up something
new to have so I mean Democrats who
aren't particularly religious suddenly
repackaging themselves as
anti-abortionists who pray a lot is
silly but people who have strong
passionate feelings learning how to
articulate them clearly in a way that
people understand them and will respond
to them positively is is something that
i think yes the democratic party needs
to do any disputes with that one yeah no
i was just going to add the first the
first time I really notice the
difference I mean I'm sure it was before
this but with what I was covering was
during the Clarence Thomas Anita Hill
hearings and it just dawned on me that
the Democrats were sort of you know
trying to figure out what really
happened while the Republicans didn't
care they were just playing to win and
they were throwing everything at this
woman and the two techniques were so
different and then I've just seen it
played out in every thing since then
like South Carolina you know McCain was
just kind of here
with everything in South Carolina to the
point where he really lost his breath
and didn't even know how to respond
because he could not believe how
personal w had been but then in the end
americans love winners so then when Bush
wins you know he has that potency of the
winner so I think the Republicans feel
you know they don't really care what the
truth of it is or what the tactics are
because they want to win and I don't
know you know again it's an ends
justifies the means things I don't think
Democrats have to stoop to those tactics
but they do have to certainly be more
muscular about how they go about
fighting next on the issue of politics
and religious cults I was wondering if
anybody had any insights on why the
mainstream media has given so little
attention to the emergence of Sun Myung
Moon as a major power broker in
Washington and why if you want to get
the truth you have to read web logs and
alternative media sources the second
article I ever published in my entire
life I want I'm really I'm kind of
pissed off about this because it's the
one time in my life I was smarter than
michael kinsley I wanted to call he
called the article in moon's orbit which
is ok I wanted to call the article bad
moon rising but anyway I wrote that
article it was in nineteen eighty three
or four or five something like that and
then it was a story and people got the
story and now they've decided that it's
not important now sometimes that's
because everybody has all the
information they need and the fact that
it's not really that important that sung
jung woon owns the Washington Times
because you know what the Washington
Times is and the other properties are
used but sometimes it's just because the
media lose interest in a certain story
and there's no way to make them
interested I think it's very interesting
that for instance on that point that
yesterday the Senate approved John
Negroponte II as head of the Democratic
ahead of the new intelligence on John
Negroponte II he's not responsible he is
we have the papers on him he he was
engaged in helping the Salvadorans
cover-up massacres in the 1980s now he
didn't even give him any green line
to have any massacres which by the way
some US officials appear to have done
but he knew that they had taken place
and he made sure that there was nothing
done to prevent future mass tourism to
stop him we have the papers we have the
memos it's all there there's no he can't
deny it and yet it's just like it's too
much of a hassle to go into it they were
fighting bolton on the one side so John
Negroponte E is getting a pass and the
vote was 98 22 and it seems to me that
there's an awful lot of issues that just
the system can handle or that that
because the dam is part of the big
problem with a debate over the war was
that the Democrats couldn't be found to
make an issue of it but there's it seems
to me that our system and it may be
there's no other way to do it but our
system so narrowly chooses what it's
going to fight about that enormous
amounts are lost and for instance to me
I think it's quite significant that we
chose the one person to be the most
influential person retire Intelligence
Committee is someone who has a past of
covering up massacres you know I think
that's pretty significant problem just
the same it seems to me strikes me the
same principles Alan Weinstein being the
head archivist I mean it's kind of like
a principle that this administration has
that you find the worst imaginable human
being for a job and you give it to them
but but again it is where where are the
media we are to me this is a question
that involves the whole panel because
it's about lying but I'm going to direct
it to Cobra woman what at this point are
the chances of Judy Miller heading for
the slammer the Martha Stewart wing of
course but the slammer nonetheless well
I guess some according to what i read in
the New York Times and good there eight
the chances are good she's going to end
up in the clink because because the Bush
administration has just kind of
systematically gone after the press and
try oh this is another thing about the
reality-based community they've tried to
replace the press it's like invasion of
the Body Snatchers with their own
version of the press people like
Armstrong Williams that are paid to you
know spread the word on on no child left
behind and Jeff Gannon you know a male
escort could get a new boy house yahoo
dog yeah could get into the White House
but my White House press was taken away
they think they can replace the press
you know and it's a very ominous and
then the ones they can't replace they'll
go after and put in jail and the amazing
the remarkable thing about Judy is she
didn't even write a story she just
thought about it so now we're into
thought police you know and its really
scary my understanding and that is they
they leaked this story to six people
five of them refused to take the story
and write about it one of them did
they're going there for the ones who
didn't write the story you know let me
just one at one thing there was a
decision came down on tuesday of last
week from the full United States Court
of Appeals District of Columbia who
turned down the appeal of miller and
cooper knowing there's something that's
interesting and lurking in this whole
story though that no one really quite
knows what's going on when Judge Hogan
the chief judge or excuse me the yeah
he's the chief judge of the district
court held the contempt citations as
valid and acted on Fitzpatrick's motion
he filed an affidavit and it's was
sealed part of the appeal was the fact
that was an ex parte proceeding and
nobody other than the prosecutor and the
judge know what's in this document but
the judge gave just enough of a hint he
said the investigation shifted during
the course of the investigation and
these are very important witnesses judge
Hogan happened to be a classmate of mine
and a friend of mine and actually when
one time my attorney he's a very
cautious man I can't believe he would
let Fitzpatrick go off on a lark so I
don't think we know all the facts here
of why Fitzpatrick feels he has to have
this testimony and why he's banging away
at this so there's the we don't have a
full complete picture to make a judgment
on it johnny is there any way you can
tell this story to yourself without
Robert Novak having testified well you
know I I think he might have taken the
fifth but why would they why would the
judge accept that why wouldn't the judge
put in the same position well then you
have to go through a whole immunity
proceeding and they may have thought it
not worth it i don't know
he is obviously there are two people who
could solve this problem one is Novak
two or whoever leaked the information if
they came forward and said hey we're the
leak we don't want a miscarriage of
justice we don't want Miller and Cooper
going to jail and are hiding behind it
but that would resolve the issue so it's
just not Novak it's also the leakers who
are the cowards in this play it's
soundbite time went down about six
minutes here so if we could keep the
questions and the answers to sound bites
and really I keep believing that george
bush or dick cheney i don't know when
first said but George Bush would more
naturally say my father got screwed out
of the pret of being reelected this guy
does Saddam Hussein did it if I get
elected president were going it in there
and we're going to take him out it
wouldn't matter 911 it wouldn't have
mattered anything somewhere I think
there's a hidden piece of paper
somewhere or something on some computer
where one of them says to the other if
you don't agree you're not on my ticket
you can't run for the believe they
hadn't planned ahead of time well i
think i think the reasons we went to war
kind of a perfect storm of reasons that
everybody had their own reason and i
think this president's reason was partly
to you know a binge and one up his
father but it played into other reasons
that the neo-cons had you know in terms
of remaking the middle east and have
played into other reasons that dick
cheney had about wanting to smack
somebody so that the Arabs wouldn't look
cross-eyed at us again and that America
could establish the principle of being a
hyper power so and Rumsfeld wanted to
prove that he could transform the
military and do things with the smaller
agile for so everybody had different
reasons and they all interlocked yeah
mornings absolutely right and it's
something to keep in mind not everything
in life has one reason lots of things in
life have many reasons it may have been
a war for oil and may have been
or for strategic strategic promised in
the Middle East it may have been a war
for Halliburton and may have been a war
for to do because he tried to kill my
daddy it may have been a war because
they wanted to kick some arab ass and
let the arabs know that that's kind of
thing they're gonna get if they Charlie
may be in any one of these things maybe
all of them beautiful was different
things and you don't need to identify
the single reason you just need to
understand how the decisions were
reached and try to reach better ones in
the future one host okay one more over
here alright so I grew up in an
evangelical Christian home and what mr.
Dean said is true they're always on the
from the pulpit a lot of times people
will say over and over again that the
left and the New York Times is out to
heat they hate christianity and they
hate God and they want to destroy
destroy us so don't read the New York
Times don't be that because they're
against you but I just want to say don't
you find in some sense though it's not
hate that they don't that it's a sound
there's a grain of truth to the
disrespect for religion on the left and
how can we expect people in the South or
even just people here in California who
religion is the center of their lives to
come over their side when our to our
side when we seem to not have respect
for what's the center of their life well
I think you've gotta distinguish between
what you mean when you say the left sure
there are people on the left you have
contempt for religion and quite open
vocal Michael Shermer for example with
respect to his views tell me
I mean no but wait a minute did you say
that Michael Michael was cautious about
that I said wait a minute there are
there are all kinds of people in all
kinds of places who believe all kinds of
things and to say that a the new york
times is the left strikes me as a
ridiculous statement but even saying say
to New York to to the equation that is
frequently made I'm not saying you made
it but you did actually go New York on
I'm just saying the perception and even
here's my players yeah but here's my
points it's easy to pick up and say oh
look Michael Moore is offensive and
therefore i hate the Democrats okay but
Michael Moore is not a democratic
candidate John Kerry was and for some
reason the you can have like a Jerry
file while saying that the United States
got what it deserved on 911 and and the
Republicans and the Conservatives
somehow don't pay a political price for
that but you have Michael Moore doing
what many people feel to be honestly
feel to be to be disrespectful of the
country in the President and yet that is
blamed the national media on the
Democratic candidate Noam Chomsky wasn't
the Democratic candidate Michael Moore
wasn't Democratic word Churchill is not
the Democratic candidate and Coulter
says you know we should kill journalist
is first cancel again and yet there's no
price to be paid so I think that part of
the problem is our culture's inability
to make these kind of distinguish was
sure there are lots of people on the
Left were contemporaries but a lot of
very religious people on the left and
and why is why is this monochromatic
picture the one that is operating in our
media's mind
John you want to ask JD yeah I want to
just point out that John Dean is the
only person on this panel who really
changed his mind about American politics
over the last 30 years that makes him
sort of a hero and as most people to the
extent that people do change their mind
in American politics as they get older
and grayer they tend to move to the
right John Dean hasn't done that and I
think that's why we appreciate him and I
just wanted to ask and I wanted to ask
what what is his secret well there's a
maybe I can answer this with a story
there's a story about George Bush being
down in Crawford and out bicycling and
went by saw a little boy in a front yard
with a box of puppies and asked the boy
what kind of puppies these word he said
they're all Republican puppies and
George said nice that's wonderful son
when bicycle down a couple about a week
later he's bicycling again with Laura
with him and he said wink said her says
can come see this and he sees little boy
with his box of puppies and he said some
what kind of puppies are those he said
they're Democrats what do you mean
they're Democrats well they opened their
eyes